today we are diving into the
groundbreaking Technologies of Chad JP
and Dal revolutionizing how we interact
with machines and perceive creativity
did you know that Chad jpd developed by
open AI has engaged Millions worldwide
answering queries with the depth of
understanding once thought impossible
for machines from composing poems to
coding its capabilities are astonishing
and then there's Dal a name that blends
the famous artist Salvador di with
pixers W this AI Marvel generates
stunning images from textual
descriptions pushing the boundaries of
digital art here's a mind-blowing fact D
can create over a quintilian unique
images that's a one followed by 18 zeros
imagine the endless possibilities for
artist designers and creatives and
before we move on just a quick info for
you if you're one of the aspiring python
Enthusiast orml Enthusiast looking for
online training and graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers in python or a
ml by learning from the experts then try
giving a short to Simply learns
postgraduate program in a ml in
collaboration with perd University and
IBM by enrolling in this certification
program you will gain expertise in
skills like generative AI prompt
engineering chat GPT explainable AI
machine learning algorithms supervised
and unsupervised learning model training
and optimization and there's much more
on the list so what are you waiting for
hurry up and enroll now a year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
these courses you can find the course
link in the description box below and
pin comment so let's get started open AI
has unveiled its latest Innovation D 3
marking a significant evolution in the
AI driven text to image Arena the
advancement from Del 2 to Del 3 is
nothing short of astounding where D 2
fell short D 3 emerged as a formidable
competitor potentially outshining even
mid journey in its
capabilities this tool is not just an
impressive technological feat it's a
practical asset for personal and
professional Endeavors in today's
tutorial we will explore optimal
strategies for leveraging Del to enhance
efficiency and reduce expenses in design
related task remarkably Del 3 is
available at no cost the excitement
surrounding this tool is well Justified
now let's understand D 3 so D 3 is the
most recent version of open ai's AI
image generator and is now a component
of Microsoft Bing Creator AI suit
broadening its availability unlike its
predecessors D 3 can generate legit text
within images and offer surprisingly
accurate representations of historical
figures and celebrities if we talk about
ethical safeguards with its official
release Del 3 implemented specific
measures to prevent misuses ensuring
responsible and ethical use of its
Advanced features D 3 is also expected
to be integrated within the chat GPD
interface which we will be using in
today's tutorial and combining Cutting
Edge image generation with sophisticated
conversational AI so this presents a
lucrative opportunity for entrepreneurs
di 3 enables the creation of remarkable
movie posters album covers logos and
more without the need for extensive
design skills this open UPS new venues
for generating Revenue through the
creation and sale of such assets so
let's start exploring Dal in integrated
with Chad jpd so we have the chat jpd 4
version and we'll start with the D
prompts and first we'll create a logo
and we'll design a logo and for that
we'll write a prompt that would be
create a prompt for a specific type of
business example coffee shop or any and
you can name the specific coffee shop
that could be Cafe Aroma so for that
we'll write a prompt that would be
create
a logo so we'll create a logo for our at
tech company only simply learn so we'll
write a prom for that create a
logo for an attech
company name simply
loan so let's see what d responds to our
prompt and what image it will generate
or what logo it will generate and
deliver to
us so you can see that it has started
the process so you could see that Dal is
creating image and you could see on the
screen
that the hover is rounding and let's
wait what Dal provides us with this
promp
so you could see that here are the two
logo designs for the educational
technology company simply learn each
design reflects a balance of modernity
Simplicity and the essence of learning
so if you want to like upgrade or if you
want to make any improvements to these
logos you could just tell the Dal and
write the prompts for it that you need
the mention of the title or the name
simply learn in the logo so it will fit
to that and provide you with the new
logos and if you need any color
combinations or something you could just
provide the prompt for that so moving on
we will see another prompt that would be
for the movie poster so for the movie
poster we will like we can write a
prompt that could be create a movie
poster for a specific genre and we can
also name the movie so let's see we can
write a
prompt so that would be
uh create a movie
poster for
a thriller
film and that would be
titled we'll title it the
dland so you could also write other
specifications also that if you want any
color combinations in the movie poster
or if you want any person doodle or any
something any objects mentioned in the
poster so you can also mention it in the
prompt so let's see what Dal responds to
this prompt so you could see like I like
this
poster so it's good so here are the two
M poster designed for the Thriller film
titled Thailand and each poster aims to
capture the suspense and mystery of the
film so if you want any upgrade or any
suggestions you can just tell the Dal
and it will do the provided results so
now we'll see the next prompt or the
next use case for the D you could also
create book covers with the help of
Dal so for that we'll write a prompt or
we could just write that would be design
a book cover for a specific genre
example mystery or Noel and here also we
can just
uh give the title name or the book name
and it will Design the book cover so
here we will write a prompt for that
that would
be design a book
cover for a
fiction uh we could add fiction
comedy and that would be and titling two
characters
entitling two characters
Noel with the
title tale of
James and another name could
be so let's see what D is responds to
this prompt so it has started creating
the
image so you could see now like totally
I like these book
covers so tale of James Fon tale of
James and Faron and the characters
are I say they are very good like Dal
has
has provided
extraordinary books so moving on uh now
we'll see the architectural design let's
see uh what Dal respond to that so we'll
write a problem for that that would be
create an architectural design of a
specific type of building example modern
house Willa so let's
see uh so we'll write a prompt
for luxury Villa create
an
architectural uh or yeah architectural
design
only of a luxury
Villa so let's see what di respond to
this and if you want any other
specification that you want any
measurements of the architectural design
or you need a particular scale sheet on
which this design should be printed so
you could ask the D to do that
also okay so you could see that it has
provided the architectural design of a
luxury Villa so this is the like the
outer design so you could also ask the D
to provide the inner design or the
blueprint of the luxury Villa so it's up
to you what you require so you could
just mold the prompts according to that
now M to the next prompt now we'll see
the 3D model so how Dal can create the
3D models using the prompt so we'll just
say that create a 3D model of a specific
image uh that could be any aircraft so
let's
see so we'll write uh create a 3D model
of a fifth generation
aircraft a 3D
model of
a fifth
generation fighter aircraft okay let's
see what does d respond to
this what kind of 3D model it will
provide so here the result you could see
that it has provided the fifth
generation
fighter and it has mentioned the
component of the fighter jet
also so here are the two designs of
fifth generation fighter aircraft
showcasing Advanced aerodynamic features
and stealth capabilities each design
reflects the sleek and aggressive nature
of modern military aviation technology
so please review them for your project
so you can review them and provide any
customizations you need for that so this
is how Dal creates the 3D model you just
have to write the prompts and D will do
the work for you now moving to the next
prompt and
here we can create tech product
prototype so we can create a prototype
design for a any ebike or solar power
ebike so let's try with that now we'll
write a problem for that that would
be uh create a
prototype and that would be
solar power only
okay and
new so let's see what T respond to this
and how it deliver the Prototype
design
Okay so here are the two prototype
design for new solar power electric bike
so it has just uh like installed the
solar panel on the bike only ebike
only so if you need any modifications or
you just need
the like the balanced or the perfect
prototype you could add the features of
the ebike here so it will mold and
create the new images or the Prototype
design according to the prompts so you
could just go and have a
conversational talk with the D and it
will like refine these images and
provide you the new
images so let's see uh another prompt
that would be
the that could be around website
homepage design like if you are creating
any website so it could just ask Del uh
we need a prototype for the website
homepage so we can write a prompt for
that that will be design the homepage so
for a specific type so we'll ask it net
designer
homepage uh and that would be for a
rental bike booking website
okay
so let's see how do respond to this so
it has started creating the
image
so I like the color combinations also
this one is
word and this is also
word so you could see that the D has
responded with the two designs for a
homepage of a Ral bike booking website
and I would definitely say that it has
provided a good
one so next we can uh generate the
images for an event poster or we can ask
it to design any cloth that could be
fashion design so let's see uh the next
one we will write for a event poster so
we will ask it that design an even
poster uh we'll ask it for a new that
just
passed let's
see and we can also give the
title so what specifications you want in
the poster or any prompt you could just
give it to the D so we'll just write
right here comes
the New Year
2024 let's see how does d respond to
this uh so you could see that it has
generated the
posters so you could just modify if you
don't need anything now that these
numbers 202 so you would just ask to
remove this and the DI would do it for
you okay so now we'll see the last one
that would be the fashion designing so
for that we'll also write a prompt and
that could be
designer any type of cloth that like we
will design a winter jacket and that to
for a men's fashion show Okay so let's
write the
PRP design of window check
it and that would be for
the men's fashion
show so it has started creating the
image and let's see what it will provide
us
with so you could see that it has
provided the image for the window jacket
for
men's so if you need any modifications
you need any
color like specific color you could ask
the chat or if you want some rounded
necks or if you want to give some
patterns provide the patterns or the
details and there you have it folks we
hope you enjoyed this insightful
tutorial if you like this session then
like share and subscribe if you have any
questions then you can drop them in the
comment section below and thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply know staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here oh